تعتقدين أن هذه ضربات قوية
في الواقع، هذه ضربة قوية عندما
يسلمك زوجك خطابًا ويطلب منك
قراءته بصوت عالٍ، ولكن يجب أن
أخبرك ضمن هذا بأنني أضع
في إشعاري الذي مدته أسبوعين أن موسم اتحاد كرة القدم الأميركي
على وشك أن يأتي  لتمرير رصيده،
لم يتمكن دان، زوج ويلسون، من تمرير هذه النكتة،
ولن أكون متاحًا للعمل في
أيام الأحد من الساعة 10 صباحًا حتى الساعة 10 مساءً. أمسيات الاثنين في أمسيات
الخميس الشمالية تفعل
الالتزامات المتضاربة العبقرية المضحكة التي لا تقدر بثمن، أرامل
كرة القدم
ومشجعي كرة القدم على حد سواء ولكن السلط
لم ينته أب ليك سيتي لطفلين من إبلاغ
زوجته بأنها كانت تحقن المضادات الحيوية الوريدية
لعلاج العدوى، سأكون متاحًا أيضًا
كل يوم سبت، ضحكت كيلي وهي تشق طريقها
خلال القراءة، ومن الواضح أنها يجب أن
تخرج منها كما علق أحد الملصقات
على الأقل سيكون لديك  أيام الثلاثاء
والأربعاء والجمعة، أبلغ دان
كالي أن الجدول الزمني سيكون
ساريًا حتى فبراير، مارس،
حصلت كالي على عروض، لذا هل الوظيفة
متاحة ومحاولة فتاة النصيحة أعلى
بدلاً من ذلك أعادت استقالته حتى
لا يتمكن من الاستقالة، لدينا نقص في الموظفين،
أطلقت صفيرًا على تلك الرسالة
Genimos الميت سي إن إن نيويورك